divide x al cuadrado menos 3 x 2 / x2
muy bien vamos a hacer división larga y
para eso voy a dibujar mi mi casita de
división entonces nos piden dividir x al
cuadrado menos 3 x 2 entre x menos 2 x 2
estas dos de estas de aquí son dos
formas de escribir la división y hay una
tercera también podemos poner esto como
x al cuadrado menos 3 x + 2 / / / x
menos 2
estas tres expresiones son equivalentes
bueno voy aquí a la de la casita para
hacer la división tenemos que fijarnos
cuáles son los términos de mayor grado
aquí el de mayor grado es x y aquí el de
mayor grado es x al cuadrado entonces
nos preguntamos cuántas veces cabe x en
x al cuadrado pues hacemos la división x
al cuadrado entre x y nos queda x
entonces cabe x veces esta x la ponemos
aquí arriba en el lugar de las x es
ahora multiplicamos x por x es x
x x menos 2 es menos 2 x lo pongo aquí
en el lugar de las x es y tenemos que
restar entonces vamos a restar y así así
así y necesito cambiar este signo es
también entonces bueno este con este se
cancelan y menos 3 x 2 x es menos x va y
estas dos bajas estas dos bajas más 2
muy bien ahora cuántas veces cabe x en
menos x pues hacemos la división menos x
entre x menos x entre x es igual a menos
uno entonces cabe menos una vez lo pongo
por aquí menos uno y hacemos la
multiplicación menos uno por x es menos
x y menos uno por menos dos es más 2
2 entonces aquí ya se ve que se cancelan
vamos a hacerlo le cambiamos el signo al
de abajo para restar este se hace más
éste se hace menos estos se cancelan y
estos de acá también se cancelan y el
residuo queda 0 muy bien déjame copiar
lo que obtuvimos aquí arriba obtuvimos
que x cuadrada menos 3 x 2 entre x menos
2 es igual a x 1 x menos 1 muy bien
podríamos verificar es más vamos a
verificar para eso tendríamos que
multiplicar x 1 con x menos dos para ver
que en efecto nos da este trinomio voy a
hacer por aquí la multiplicación
entonces x menos 1 por x 2 vamos a ver
si de adeveras da entonces menos 2 x
menos 1 es 2 en este lugar es más dos
menos dos por x es menos 2 x menos 2 x x
x menos 1 es menos x y x x x s x
cuadrada x cuadrada muy bien vamos a
hacer la suma el 2 no se suma con nada
que era como más
x con menos 2 x es menos 3x y finalmente
el x al cuadrado no se suma con nadie
queda x al cuadrado y si al hacer la
multiplicación x menos 1 por x menos 2
regresamos a x al cuadrado menos 3 x más